we're so honored to welcome a real life
hometown hero right here to the desk
she's a drew gooder and she's from
philly who spent 30 years educating and
cultivating the kids who grew up here
this year in such a challenging time for
students she launched cooks with books a
virtual experience that pairs cooking
with literacy this is so up our alley
take a look at this
so we're making petite peach pies and i
already made some they're already
delicious i tried them i'm going to show
you them later
but i'm also reading a super fun book
today this is called the night i follow
the dog now please give a hometown
welcome to a true philly hero it's marie
lambert yes
thank you so much
i am so excited to be here this is just
awesome i mean you really like as a
teacher and
a nurturer what happened to you in life
that you know
set you on a path to care about kids so
much
i was born into an uh
educator-rich family really so my father
didn't have a lot of formal education
but he believed that his children should
all be educated i want to talk about i
want to talk about what you're doing
you're a non-profit true way youth
empowerment foundation it's been going
for a decade now yes that's incredible
what is your mission so our mission is
to empower inspire and enlighten young
people to tap into their greatness to
think outside to box to be problem
solvers and critical thinkers
and to build a strong character we do a
series of games and activities to have
them really work through
um a problem without um getting angry or
using foul language or
violence
they really have to use their minds to
really think about
what they would do and how they would
solve a problem
now the pandemic put a pause on the
cause and on your conference but you've
got a very special plan for this year
will you tell us about it i am so
excited because true way is set to put
on the best youth virtual conference uh
ever uh january 2022
right the think outside the box
conference the content of your character
is a theme of it and we are set to
invite educators and professionals in
all areas of industry business the art
science health and wellness and put on
the best virtual conference ever amazing
that's so cool we are just so inspired
by your beautiful work for philly's
young people so we reached out to our
friends at jada toys and they make the
be kind dolls an eco-friendly line that
promotes messages of kindness and
inspires kids to be creative and
compassionate and
they want to recognize you with your
kindness um with the twenty thousand
dollar donation
to true way youth empowerment foundation
to help and enable all the work that you
do marie
[Applause]
i mean you're molding minds and hearts
marie you're extraordinary so here you
go yes
thank you jada toys and be kind dolls
and thank you marie lambert for being
here thank you so much for having me
this was a blast
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you i appreciate
it well thank you marie and thank you
rossie we got to go to philly
oh my god
[Music]